finally on gender you'll have seen
policy exchanges report today claiming
that parents have been kept in the dark
in some schools about their children
changing gender are you concerned what
is your government doing so I'm very
concerned about these reports you know
for me the the safety and well-being of
our children is of Paramount importance
and I've also been clear that parents
must be able to know what is being
taught to their kids in school
especially on these sensitive areas
that's why we're already reviewing the
rhse guidance to make sure that it is
age-appropriate for children but also
what I'm also going to say today is that
for the summer term we will make sure
that we publish guidance for schools so
that they know how to respond when
children are asking about their gender
these are really sensitive areas it's
important that we treat them sensitively
and that parents know what's going on
and will make sure that that happens